right now the north las vegas city
council is deciding whether two station
casino properties can keep their
licenses while they stay closed texas
station and fiesta rancho have been
shuttered since the pandemic with no
known reopening date
meantime construction underway at
another location durango resort sally
jaramillo spoke to people about the
future of those properties
i don't know why it's been closed since
the pandemic started i don't think it
will do any good at all if it just sits
here david levitt has lived in las vegas
all of his life these buildings are more
than just casinos for him they are
memories made with his family we used to
really enjoy the buffets the mexican
restaurant that was here it was all
we had a lot of fun and a lot of good
dinners here and son andrew levitt
agrees so when i was a kid um you know
my parents usually had late uh shifts so
they would get out at a later time eight
nine and not everything's open at that
point where you can go to dinner but
texas and fiesta work fast forward to
now be an adult i mean the best bowling
alley you can go to you know great movie
theaters and still it kept that
inexpensive cost for us andrew levitt
worries if these properties continue to
just sit the neighborhood will change
anything sits too long it invites the
wrong kind of
attention and trouble and so you know i
would hate to see it just turn into land
that's not available for the public
another concern for the community i'm
sure takes jobs away from this community
a lot of times you tend to want to live
and work in the same area if they do
something with that revitalize it build
something new as long as it's for the
public and it can bring families over
there i mean that's what vegas needs
sally garamillo live local now